it's not just the scientists and it's
not just Rubio Maria Elvira Salazar one
in Miami-Dade she is a Republican and a
Latina don't tell AOC we won thank you
to all of my amazing supporters 2022 is
the year of the Hispanic Republicans and
here's a bit of her victory speech
until tonight because 2022 has been the
year of the Hispanic Republicans okay so
we're going to throw to some locals
comments in just a moment we've got a
great cold close for you uh but I think
you see why I did Today's Show the way I
did uh we can always get lost in every
little battle and worrying about every
little thing and you know in politics
you're gonna win some and you're going
to lose some the irony is as I sit here
right at this very moment because Nevada
and Georgia and Arizona because those
Senate seats are still up in the up for
grabs it's like the Red Wave still may
happen we actually don't know but either
way by no estimation was a disaster and
even if it was a freaking disaster all
over the country you always need a
bright spot you need as Jordan Peterson
talks about you need that star in the
distance to look to so that you can go
towards that well it is here in Florida
so I know I'm heavy-handed when it comes
to Florida and I talk about Ron DeSantis
a lot and I talk about what we're doing
a lot but I think in some ways it was it
for me just for me personally what
happened here two days ago and what is
happening here every second of every day
is a culmination of of the ideas that
I've fought for and for the for the
the fact that I picked up my life and
the life of all these people that that
I'm involved with and we came here and
did it and if you do that you feel the
rewards of that right you get your just
dessert you really can